- There's sort of a mixed
story about pandemics.
You know Ebola and Zika, MERS and SARS,
Lassa fever, swine flu, bird flu.
There's been more animal viruses
jumping from animals to humans
in the last 30 years
than we have records of before,
and that's worrisome.
But much more worrisome than that
is that the institutions
that normally keep us safe
are sort of AWOL.
In the Ebola outbreak,
Obama sent 3,500 American
soldiers to West Africa,
we spent billions of dollars,
because WHO failed in
its job to protect us,
'cause it took six months
to correctly identify
what the disease was that was
killing people in West Africa.
So WHO is gonna have a new
director general in May
and I think it's gonna go through
a period of self-examination,
and it's offline.
And I think this presidency,
as far as pandemics, is offline.
You're not gonna see public health,
let alone pandemic preparedness,
at the top of the priority
list for this White House.
And they fired the head of CDC
and they're cutting the budgets.
- Center for Disease Control.
- Center for Disease Control,
or Centers for Disease Control, actually.
And Trump is cutting the budget
for public health and
pandemic preparedness.
There's a new secretary general of the UN
who just began on the first of January.
A really good guy,
Portuguese guy, really good,
but he's just getting started.
So if you look at those agencies
that normally keep us safe,
the federal government,
WHO, the UN, CDC,
they're all offline.
We've got a great head of the World Bank
who's a doctor, Jim Kim.
He'll be working really hard.
But by and large,
we have to have a safety
net to protect us,
to stop pandemics, to end
the threat of pandemics.
April 7th is World Health Day.
It is also the 100th anniversary
of the Great Influenza,
the Spanish influenza,
the 1917 to 1918 pandemic.
One of my grandparents died in that,
one of Girija's grandparents died in it.
I wonder how many other
people know that in your,
you know, in your genealogy,
some of your relatives died from that.
Because somewhere between 25 million
and a hundred million people
died in that one year period.
And if you put that to today's numbers,
you're talking about 75 to 300 million.
If we had a pandemic 1/10th
of that, 1/100th of that,
it would bring humanity to its knees.
There wouldn't be an airplane
in the sky for six months.
Who's gonna get on a
cargo boat with 300 people
whose epidemiological
status you don't know
when there's no vaccine and no antiviral?
I want us to stop the risk of pandemics.
We know almost every,
well, we know every step to take.
We know how to do it.
There will inevitably be outbreaks.
There'll be viruses jumping
from animals to humans.
Outbreaks are inevitable,
but pandemics are optional.
We don't have to have them
if we have the same
public will to end them
that we had to eradicate smallpox
and that's what I'm hoping
that we can pull off next.